the Joe Rogan experience yeah that's
that's all very promising you know it's
it's really interesting too because this
has become such a hot political topic
you know there's so many people that are
angry at Trump but they were angry at
Trump back when he was closing the
Travel from China which turned out to be
a great idea and you know Donald Trump
jr. tweeted today a compilation of CNN
and all these other different networks
giving out bad information way back in
January bad information saying this is
going to be fine don't worry you know
it's not as deadly as the fluish worried
about the flu you know don't change your
plans don't do anything so a lot of
people got this wrong and but so many
people are trying to make this a
political point right now and it's
really it's so so useless it's you know
pointing fingers and everything at this
point in time it's like what they need
to concentrate on now is just getting
masks getting PPE equipment keeping
people healthy if they can and then
educating people on how to keep your
immune system strong and let's you know
let's try to let's try to get people to
understand the consequences of not
taking care of your body this has to be
the worst job in the world president no
matter what no matter what you do
everyone's gonna have to people are
gonna hate you who would want that job
because it doesn't even pay that well
compared to other professions at the top
end of other professions you know it
there's a lot of articles now about how
autocrats around the world have been
taking advantage of the of the pandemic
to increase their power
yes well civil liberties you know in
Hungary and and in Turkey even Israel
China of course Putin and Russia and so
on and trump usually gets lumped in
there like he's an autocrat like obon
and and everyone and and Netanyahu and
and so forth okay
so then so had he closed let's say do
the counterfactual let's say he closed
the borders in late January or early
February or something like this I mean
just just just clamp down on all travel
and so on he would have been totally
accused of being an autocrat he's you
know he wants to be a dictator and look
what he
doing yeah okay so he doesn't do that
and then he's accused of you know not
doing enough when it looks like we
should have done more and then you know
the other day when he said well I'm not
gonna I'm not going to tell all the
governor's what to do you know I'm gonna
honor states rights for now and of
course he gets hammered for that it's
like but you know but that's actually
what I'm supposed to do that's not what
an autocrat would do and all that crap
would say yeah I'm telling everybody
what to do right exactly no you know I
think maybe we should you know drop all
the polarization politically rally
around the president even if you hate
him just look what happened after 9/11
yeah I mean Bush was pretty hated by the
left and and most liberals came around
said all right you know what we're gonna
support this guy at least for a few
months until you know we figure out
what's going on here and most of the
Liberal Democratic congressmen and
senators voted for the war and you know
for the invasion of Afghanistan and
including Iraq
including Hillary right so you know
maybe we ought to do that I know people
just can't stand Trump and just the idea
like saying something nice or supportive
or not being critical seems hard to do
but you know maybe this is way worse
than 9/11 yeah it's your what you're
saying is totally correct it's it seems
like the polarization is even worse than
the one it was in 2001 it seems like it
just keeps ramping up and Trump is such
a naturally polarizing figure that it's
gotten you know the the left versus
right has gotten so extreme right now
it's almost impossible for rational
discourse and this is one of the reasons
why it's a good time now to talk about
your book giving the devil too I'm just
showing this graph of the people that
self identify as centrist versus now
which is more polarized you have this
two-hump camel here and that's from 2019
94 2004 and then close to today when did
that shift is that a trump shift that
low no no no no about 2000 well really
under Obama about 2008 the polarization
got worse and worse
I mean we can speculate why but that's
pretty much when it happened a bit
around 2004-2005 and it gets ramped up
so just pollsters asking people you know
how do you self-identify you know
centrist far-left far-right you know
strong Republican strong Democrat where
and so that middle ground has been is
been shrinking the center's have been
shrinking and the polls have been
increasing so more and more people are
polarize now you know conservative talk
radio and television or you know it's
MSNBC you know whatever you want to
accuse the media but but in general I
think we've just been more polarized in
the sense of not just saying well I
disagree with you I think you're wrong
but that you're evil you're you're
you're immoral you know this is you know
the the worst thing that's ever happened
to us and so on this kind of ramping up
of the catastrophism you know it's not
healthy
[Applause]